mein thema handelt vom lifestyle
feminismus feminismus es erstmal etwas
großartiges etwas tolles etwas so
wichtiges denn wir haben noch nicht in
allen bereichen die gleichberechtigung
erreicht doch in den letzten monaten
stört mich immer mehr der livestream ihn
ist muss was ich damit meine das sieht
man hier zum beispiel ins zugelost die
posten go girls go go girl das zum
beispiel sind immer so einfache poster
zeigen frauen sollen gefördert werden
wenig inhalt einfach nur ein schlagwort
will queens fix in jaggers falls ja was
soll das dem feminismus stand bringen
doch nicht nur die instagram post stören
mich massiv nein mich widert auch der
lifestyle feminismus in form von events
an hier möchte ich klar sagen
selbstverständlich bestätigt die
ausnahme die regel aber viele viele
events sind doch nicht mehr als rosa
gekündigte abendessen wo frauen
nebeneinander sitzt er schon panja glas
erheben um für frauen zu kämpfen man
muss dazu sagen junge frauen die am
anfang ihrer karriere sind sind meistens
nicht eingeladen es sind viel zu oft
frauen die er schon obenauf sind und
miteinander über den feminismus reden
ich finde das falsch der life der
feminismus tut unserer gesellschaft
nicht gut wir haben probleme zu klären
aber nicht in dem frauen sich eigentlich
gegenseitig nur ja darstellen wollen
oder mit rosa übertünchten slogans auf
bürger etwas aufmerksam machen wollen ja
vielleicht sogar mit sich selbst war
feminismus ist der die der der früher
von alice schwarzer gelebt wurde
janina ich kann jetzt natürlich jetzt
nicht mit polemisieren gegen diese girls
only events den leider leider in ihnen
nämlich zu selten ein girls und die
events teil aber was mich ein bisschen
irritiert am gegenwärtigen feminismus
feminismus debatte ist dass medizin
richtungen nicht ganz klar ist ich
verstehe ist vorkommenden frauen sich
gegenseitig unterstützen ich erlebe es
aber dass
in der debatte eigentlich alles
männliche als als gewaltig und und
toxisch gilt und das runter und
irgendwas fraulicher als als das als das
vernünftige und liebevolle nun scheint
der feminismus darauf ausgerichtet zu
sein frauen in meiner position zu
bekommen und die sich an assimilieren
das heißt die die ideale vermisst die
frau ist dann genauso toxischen
gewalttätig wieder wie der mann und der
mann ist zur seite gedrängt ich verstehe
die zielrichtung nicht also wollen
frauen mehr nie mehr werden wie männer
dann wäre das eine schlechte nachricht
in die welt oder wollen sie sein und
oder wollen sie bleiben die frauen und
damit einfach nur aus sicht ihre
softskills
berufen dass diese zielsetzung ist schon
eine sehr wichtige frage aber allein
schon sein erster satz ich kann ja nicht
so viel zu viel millionen event sagen
weil ich da jetzt man ja nicht bin ich
frage mich immer was bringen viele
events sind also im großen man kann
natürlich mainz machen aber es gibt hier
überall frauen ohne events frauen ohne
ladies lunches alles mögliche ich frage
mich immer warum sind nicht auch männer
eingeladen weil die gleichberechtigung
schaffen wir doch nur mit mann und frau
gemeinsam was wäre denn jetzt wenn
männer jetzt jeder von euch anwesen
würde jetzt ein boys ohne klub gründen
den boys club oder ein boys ohne event
der aufschrei wäre riesig in der
gesellschaft und ich finde manch ein
mann wie zb mein vater ist ein größerer
vermin ist als viele frauen und deswegen
nervt mich schon diese mann/frau
einteilung sind wir da nicht schon viel
weiter
ich glaube nicht dass wir weiter sind
wir sehen ja dass wir jetzt vier männer
ober für minister muss diskutieren ich
glaube die frauen haben noch ein langer
weg und wie auch männer weil wir
profitieren natürlich von einem gesunden
feminismus wir profitieren wenn unsere
töchter und unsere frauen auch die
besseren chancen und auf augenhöhe mit
uns auch konkurrieren zusammenleben
wollen ich glaube ist es wichtig dass
diese feminismus debatte da ist aber wir
haben zwei sorten von von feminismus sie
haben ja wurde du hast ja alles
schwarzer die ist nicht der
vergangenheit diese art von feminismus
existiert und dass alles wieder viele
frauen aber diese neue art von
feminismus der eigentlich
männerfeindlich mitbringt der eigentlich
so zu sagen da unrecht sieht wo es
ideologisch passt und ehrenmorde und
kopftuchzwang und zwangsverheiratung den
minderheiten stattfinden gar nicht sehen
will und relativiert oder verharmlost
das ist ein ideologisch geladener
feminismus der eigentlich den kampf für
minister muss nicht weiterbringt und
dann startet ich frage mich immer wenn
du sagst der feminismus wien alice
schwarzer lädt das ist der film nist
muss den du gut findet der familie ist
muss den alice schwarzer gerät hat man
euch trend lebt mindestens eine
generation um gleich ein bisschen oder
zwei oder drei sogar aber vielleicht
auch noch ein bisschen mehr von der
einstellung vielleicht auch von der
optik her
aber ich frage mich was du damit meinst
und ich wundere mich ein bisschen dass
die frauen so jetzt bestehen auf diese
women sony sachen weil wir mit sony gab
es in anderer form mir früher noch ich
habe das erlebt früher in hamburg weil
sich noch war ich eingeladen bei leuten
und dagegen die männer nach dem essen in
die bibliothek und die frauen dann
direkt im salon ja gut das war dann
nicht die küche sondern der sogenannte
salon aber da gab es diese trennung
gmünder um bis zu besprechen ich war da
natürlich noch klein und guckte nur zu
und die frau durfte man nebenan sich
unterhalten jetzt haben wir das ganze
jetzt würden wahrscheinlich die frauen
in die bibliothek gehen nach dieser
einstellung die männer müssten in die
küche oder in den in den salon aber was
bringt uns diese diese grundsätzlich
aber mehr noch interessiert warst du
meinst du sagt der feminismus von alice
schwarzer das ist deiner nein ich habe
gesagt dass früher der vermissten von
alice schwarzer dass es auch ein großes
thema aber zum beispiel sie hat themen
gemacht und auch themen gesetzt dass die
tonnen schon absolut ich sage auch nicht
dass ich alles an ihr gut finde
überhaupt nicht aber es ging um themen
zb sie hat die ema gegründete haben
frauen dann inhalte auch bekommen oder
damals ihr stern titel wir haben
abgetrieben im nachhinein weiß und es
waren ja gar nicht alle frauen die
abgetrieben haben sie hatten nicht übel
aber seinen standpunkt zum thema gesetzt
und damit was verändert oder auch ihre
bücher dem die angefangen mit 16 zu
lesen aber es war ein standpunkte sie
hat auch gerade dem deutschlandfunk ganz
spannendes interview gegeben dass wenn
frauen also der tenor wenn frauen mehr
zusammenarbeit würden werden wir weiter
es ging um themen sie hat darüber
geschrieben was mich an diesem leids der
feminismus so abschreckt und ich glaube
er tut der gesellschaft auch nicht gut
bei dadurch dass jetzt überall diese
ganzen gleichberechtigung feminismus
gender pay gap ganz schnell ins um
instagram post runtergebrochen und man
hat ihr das gefühl finde ich überall
wird schon darüber geredet es gibt
nichts mehr zu tun und ich fand schon
bei alice schwarzer die intellektualität
auch mit der sich der sache gewidmet hat
hatte für mich mehr als wenn er 20
frauen sich zusammensetzt noch mit rosa
champagner darauf anstoßen dass sie was
für minister muss tun wollen sie hat ihr
leben dem feminismus aber lena das ist
ja eigentlich ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches phänomen wir
betreiben symbole wie betreibe
symbolpolitik wir sitzen nicht auf
wir wollen die wollen nur ländern aber
interessiert uns nicht ob es
gleichberechtigung herrscht ja oder nein
und das ist halt die generation von
instagram und sozialen medien die
einfach innerhalb von zwei sekunden
irgendwas vermitteln wollen und es
bleibt einfach oberflächlich war
eigentlich ist den frauen ganz einfach
lustig unter sich zu sein also ich bin
manchmal
finde ich völlig in ordnung ich gehe
auch gerne meine freundin essen bringen
nicht diskriminiert und solche runden
pro team er sich dann von den frauen
verabschieden und unter sich bleiben und
witze reißen also das finde ich hier
ganz angenehm gerade beim predigen zum
beispiel also ich bin auch gerne mit
meinen freunden zugegangen
ich warte nur noch darauf das ist ein
joghurt gibt mit der aufschrift vielmehr
friendly also das ist mein problem das
ist so missbraucht wird die viel mehr im
parlament bewegung man kann sich auch
einfach mit 30 frauen beispielsweise im
restaurant treffen ohne viel mehr im
parlament darüber zu schreiben und das
ist mein großes problem daran aber wenn
wir es positiv sehen meinst du nicht
eine liste von auch im push ausgibt nach
dem motto dass viele das sehen die sonst
nicht in berührung damit komme ich meine
du sicherlich aber es gibt doch viele
leute in deutschland die nicht jeden
abend die gelegenheit haben sich mit
solchen leuten zu treffen und so wie
vielleicht davon so ein impuls bekommen
und hey
das ist vielleicht eine idee für mich
mich auch weiter zu bilden oder
weiterzuentwickeln oder dinge
anzustreben die ich die ich nicht für
möglich gehalten haben immer noch obwohl
wir so schauen wir so gleichberechtigt
sind ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
es besser wäre wenn das thema feminismus
männer und frauen gemeinsam klären und
es halt nicht diese gruppen entstehen
wie der frauen und männer getrennt ich
finde das schwierig aber
selbstverständlich vielleicht hilft so
und instagram spruch der schnell
geschrieben ist irgendwie man sich damit
auseinandersetzt einer reform zum
separatismus jede form von st
separatismus ist bescheuert und was im
moment sehen ist ja eine
absolute der renaissance des des
separatismus es werden statt dass wir
uns als gemeinschaft in seiner
unterschiedlichkeit zusammenfinden
spalten wir uns untereinander auf ist ja
längst nicht mehr frauen das nächste ist
dann rothaarige frauen und rothaarige
frauen mit denen die hinten und ich noch
nicht werde ich werde demnächst ein
journalist erinnerten
in eine selbsthilfegruppe aufmachen für
für für weiße die sich in einem körper
eines schwarzen gefangen fühlen weil ich
bin in afrika geboren ich habe mich als
schwarzarbeit eben niemals irgendwelche
vorteile also ich immer ich mache sagt
deshalb aus witz dieses ständige sich
aufspalten im separat identitäten ist
das absolute gegenteil von das was man
gesellschafter in eine gesellschaft ist
kommt in ihrer unterschiedlichkeit
zusammen verhandelt unter untereinander
auch die verschiedenen interessen und
findet dann einen gemeinsamen nenner was
im moment erleben ist ein separates
musste geht ja längst nicht mehr
richtung frauen sondern frauen uns nach
farbe es wird es wird alles mit der
vp-chef gelaufen das system hatte
eigentlich wissen wir haben hier immer
ein jeder hat er seinen zehn minuten
sendezeit aber das war das perfekte
schlusswort alexander hat eigentlich in
worte gefasst was ich fühle und
wahrscheinlich am anfang meinem monolog
nicht so zum ausdruck gebracht das sehe
ich ganz genauso